so just in the introduction
they say in the most recent centers for
disease control and prevention analysis
of available national data among
individuals diagnosed with covet-19
a 35 year old with diabetes mellitus
hypertension
cardiovascular disease obesity or other
chronic conditions
had a similar risk of coping 19 related
hospitalization i was a 35 year old with
one of the core morbidities
as a 75 year old with none of these
conditions
and a similar risk of covet 19 related
death as a 65 year old with none of
these conditions
a dramatic biologic aging effect of poor
metabolic health on risk of severity of
a viral infection such as covet 19.
so that is a pre-existing piece of
research from the cdc that this paper
is citing and then
here is this is just the paper it's in
the journal of the american heart
association
o'hearn it all just published and i'm
just going to read their
set-aside box here clinical perspective
what is new meaning what is new in this
paper
patients with cardiometabolic conditions
in particular obesity hypertension
diabetes mellitus and heart failure
have a high risk of poor outcomes from
coronavirus disease 2019 infection
that's actually not new we already knew
that those are some of the major
comorbidities for covered 19 for bad
outcomes
and for actually getting the disease at
all among night among more than 900 000
u.s coronavirus disease
2019 hospitalizations through november
18
2020 nearly two-thirds 63.5 percent
were estimated to be attributable to
these cardiometabolic conditions that is
preventable if these conditions had not
been present
top risks were obesity uh which is
explaining 30 percent
of that nearly two-thirds hypertension
at 26
diabetes mellitus at 21
and then heart disease was i think about
12 or so
and then what are the clinical
implications clinicians should educate
their patients who may be at risk and
consider promoting preventative
lifestyle measures such as improved
dietary quality and physical activity
to improve overall cardio metabolic
health and potentially minimize the risk
for coronavirus disease 2019
severity at some level
again assuming that they have done this
you know sort of like
massive data review and analysis
accurately which includes lots of places
where there are models so
lots of places for it not to have been
done brilliantly um
at some level i feel like finally
finally someone is doing this kind of
work
and talking directly about
about actually what makes you as an
individual
more likely to have a bad outcome among
those factors that you actually
potentially have control over
you know there's been a lot of talk
about age
and it's true right the older you are
the more at risk you are of getting
and of of having a poor outcome from the
disease but you can't do anything about
that we don't we don't have the solution
to that yet
sex uh men are more likely to both get
slightly and have bad outcomes more so
um
copen19 than women and then race and
actually
um to some degree uh black people but
really
latina what would what is often
described as hispanic people
um have um much worse
outcomes compared to their um you know
many more hispanics are affected than
you would expect from background rates
of hispanics in the population
so those are those are all true things
about which you can't do anything
right you can't just frankly you can't
just declare yourself a different age or
a different sex or a different race
right but these comorbidities
you potentially can not all of them and
not if you're really
you know really far gone but
if you start to eat better
and be more active in your life you can
reduce
your obesity and your hypertension and
potentially deal with your diabetes
mellitus
all of these are at least affected by
and in some cases
majorly affected by lifestyle choices
so i of course fully agree with that and
there is an
obvious discussion to be had about the
absurdities of this moment and the idea
that to discuss such things is to
pretend that a particular body form is
more healthy when in fact of course a
particular body form is more healthy
now i'm fat shaming right you could be
dismissed as fat shaming into the extent
that the data
seemed to reflect that this is not fat
shaming this is just analysis then we
can also complain
that data the very idea of data logic
science is white supremacist whatever it
is and so obviously
the right analysis is no none of that is
true right and it's not to say science
hasn't been put to bad ends or
bent to particular populations desires
or needs or whatever
of course it has but the point is those
tools are actually
indifferent to who you are if you use
them right and
the the thing that i want to point out
is that
there's a whole set of analyses that one
wants
in effect there are going to be dozens
of factors
involved in how likely you are to
contract cover 19
and what happens to you after you do
right type o blood
appears to be involved it seems to be
somewhat protective as compared to type
a
so we talked about that in like our
first or second live stream and i
haven't seen anything
about that for many months now have you
seen anything else yes i did to see
something recent but i don't have it
uh maybe but that seems to be holding
seems to behold okay
um but here's here's the point type o
blood
is not going to be independent of all
these other factors so
does the fact that uh black people and
hispanic people are facing
more covid does that hold if we control
for vitamin d
probably because the comparison between
blacks and hispanics
likely involves blacks making less
vitamin d as a result of just
being on average darker or if we control
for obesity and hypertension rates
right and so that's what you really want
to do is figure out how many of these
things are correlated
indirectly through something else right
through through
cultural factors right how many people
live in a household can have effects
um uh you know it could be genetic
factors but indirect
like melanin production and its
interface with vitamin d production
one of the things we talked about
earlier a paper you brought to the
discussion was
um the the local subway lines that
people were forced to take
more people were more likely to be
forced to take to get to work if they
lived in low-income
areas in new york city this was a new
york city-based subway now right which
was a beautiful case
of something that had nothing to do
inherently with biology but was having
impacts on biology by virtue of the way
the city is constructed right
um the neighborhoods in the city were
effectively
segregated by ethnicity and so people of
certain ethnicities were at more risk of
getting the thing
because they happened to live in places
and were taking these subway lines where
they were stuck in these tiny
cars with lots of people getting on and
off all the time
so um anyway one wants the analysis of
variance that picks apart all of the
factors figures out which ones are
actually directly
correlated and which ones evaporate when
you control
for their connection to other things and
then
you would be maximally armed and so in
some sense we all carry around this you
know
this stuff from the beginning which is
very probably true
in fact it's hard to imagine how it's
false that age
is this dominant factor but the point is
okay
if in effect obesity causes you to
behave like somebody who's much older
right with respect to contracting covet
19 then the point is well you don't have
control over the age
but you might have control over the
obesity right and so
thinking in these terms like okay we all
probably have a few
tick marks against us with respect to
covet 19 and then we have some other
places
where you know we may have uh the
opportunity to do something and the
question is well how low can you get
your risk and you know if you can't get
your risk metabolically low
maybe you need to correct for it
behaviorally right
so the point is armed with information
you are in the best position
to manage this which also means stopping
the focus
on death which is of course you know
death is very important but
from the point of view of actually you
may get over this thing but it may rob
you of a decade
of life by virtue of what it's done to
your lungs or your circulatory tissue
that's a very important factor and um
anyway
the only right answer here is for us to
figure out how to do these analyses so
they're not polluted
so that our information and therefore
our models both formal and informal get
better over time which then arms us
maximally to protect ourselves
and to you know to to uh to choose our
future you know collectively
like at what point do we um you know say
well this is under control
enough that we have to prioritize
the world moving forward right that's a
discussion we can only have if we have
really good information
on where we are and what our actual
risks are yes no that's right
and um you know unfortunately all of the
new variants are making that
conversation even harder to have
um because oh you know we
we might have expected in fact i think
we predicted early on
um that um this was you know
this this is likely to become less
virulent over time it's effectively
i and i and i have seen a number of
other scientists propose this is likely
to become just a circulating background
disease that
effectively children get exposed to
and thus have some immunity to going
forward
um i don't know and i've seen no one
attempt an analysis of
what these different variants that
are wildly different in terms of both
transmissibility
and death rate might do to that analysis
right
or even like how we proceed with
analysis in the light of those really
and you know i mean we've got two novel
factors here
one the ultimate wild card if this isn't
a natural virus if this is a modified
virus
then it will not abide by our
expectations uh evolutionarily that are
based on
what wild viruses do when they jump now
it's also
quite possible that it would be novel in
its own right having jumped from nature
with
no human tinkering maybe this is just
going to follow a different pattern and
we're going to learn something about
viruses we didn't know
but if it's modified if it is enhanced
then one expects a very different
pattern to
emerge from this the other thing is that
these vaccines
are it is increasingly clear to me that
these vaccines
are novel not only with respect to the
frightening
interaction that they have with systems
where we can't predict what the
long-term impact is going to be because
we haven't seen it yet and
you're talking specifically about the
mrna vaccines or also about the dna
vaccine so just to
so and we've talked a lot about vaccines
on the show before but we've got
uh pfizer and moderna fiso and pfizer
and bioentech and modern
vaccines those two which are widespread
in the u.s at this point which are both
mrna vaccines
and you've got the astrazeneca oxford
vaccine which it looks like
is not going to be available in the us
but is available a few other places and
johnson johnson
which may be about to get fda approval
in the u.s both of those astrazeneca and
johnson and johnson
are dna vaccines also not traditional
but they use a delivery mechanism of an
adenovirus
rather than these lipid nanoparticles
yep and i
see in you know various comments that we
get uh in various places we're having
trouble conveying
uh the evolutionary uh approach
here so to the extent that the
astrazeneca and johnson and johnson
vaccines
are not um a tried and true
technology they're somewhat more tried
and true than the lipid nanoparticles
that are used for the mrna vectors one
part of them is tried and true
right one part of them is more
traditional vaccine-wise but what it
also
is is something that we have
evolutionary experience with that has
nothing to do with vaccines that is to
say
experience with adenoviruses right so
that experience with adenoviruses that
our ancestors and
probably each of us has had actually
makes this safer
as well but in any case
the so when i'm talking about the novel
factor of the vaccines i'm actually
talking about
so we really got two categories we've
got the mrna vaccines and their lipid
nanoparticles
and the adenovirus vaccines dna vaccines
and their adenoviruses just to be very
careful about mrna with lipid
nanoparticles dna
with adenovirus so the adenovirus
vaccines are carrying their information
in the form of dna
which then gets translated into rna
which then creates spike protein which
then alerts the immune system exactly as
the
mrna vaccines do but
there is another unique factor here
which has nothing to do with the
delivery mechanism
at all in which in both in all four
of these vaccines the two different
categories
for vaccines and that is that we are
very narrowly targeting the spike
protein and by very narrowly targeting
the spike protein we are creating
a uh an evolutionary a concentrated
evolutionary force
whereas cruder more primitive vaccine
technologies
that you know take a a whole virus
and either break it up or neutralize its
pathogenic effect
those things are much more general and
so
the compare so be more precise about
that but when you say they're much more
general
you're basically you're giving your body
and attenuated
or you know pieces of the original virus
and your body can then develop
an ability to recognize lots of
different parts of that
whereas the four vaccines that we named
the two mrna and the two dna vaccines
only provide the body with an ability to
recognize the spike protein
which means that if the spike protein is
to change just to
list one possible problem with this if
the spike protein is to evolve
then um all the all of these four
vaccines
um are rendered useless
not useless uh less useful less useful
but
it does two things i mean this is the
thing we're in
if this weren't so politicized this
would be incredibly fascinating
so politicized and so dangerous this
would be fascinating because what we're
doing
is experimenting with a much more
targeted
vaccine right narrowly targeted that
narrowly targeted vaccine
increases the likelihood of our vaccines
becoming
more useless over time because we're
creating a very
precise attack that the virus will be
favored to resist
however it also creates the possibility
of effectively swapping out the
information
in these vaccines without going through
the rest of it
which is part of why at least i mean i i
know much less about
the dna vaccine development but the mrna
vaccine development
has the potential to be so fast and
indeed apparently one of them i don't
remember which was actually
created in a weekend back in like
february or march of last year
and you know if they turn out to be as
safe and effective as the whole world is
hoping that they are
um then this really does mean that
future pandemics could be halted pretty
quickly
with you know widespread inoculation by
uh
new you know rapidly developed mrna
vaccines potentially
now what you really want to know is how
much of the variance
in the risk that comes with these things
is due
to the delivery mechanism and how much
is due to the
uh the informational content whether
it's in mrna or dna
because if the danger is
in the informational content then you
can't
uh make the safety process rep more
rapid
right you have to go through it on the
other hand right
if the danger is really in the delivery
mechanism then a
maybe we can refine that right we can
reduce the danger and still get the
delivery
and then b swap out the information
and you could even imagine a future not
so far down the road
where you might not have to have
centralized creation of these things you
could have you know effectively like
printing newspapers
in each town right you could have a
factory 3d printing for vaccines
the equivalent right you could have that
sort of thing taking place so that as
the thing as we got really good at
tracking uh pathogens and epidemics
we would also get really good at
delivering you know it could be targeted
in the sense that your
vaccine could be built for the
particular strains that are circulating
in your municipality
so anyway there's lots of possibilities
here
but boy what a dangerous experiment
we're discovering this stuff
[Music]
in
you